the greens versus the blacks HBO's House
of the Dragon has the Targaryen family
hurtling toward a Civil War for the Iron
Throne that will split the realm in two
this Targaryen infighting nicknamed the
dance of the Dragons has revealed two
main factions with Queen Alison
Hightower leading the greens and
Princess rhaenyra Targaryen leading the
blacks but just who are the greens and
the blacks and which dragons are on each
side
[Music]
yo will go over why they're called the
greens and the blacks who supports each
faction who's still undecided and how
many dragons each side has also I'll try
to avoid any spoilers for the entire
video for those of you who haven't read
the book Fire and Blood and are just
enjoying House of the dragon as it comes
out so to understand exactly who the
greens and the blacks are we need to
First understand what started the dance
of the Dragons as we saw in House of the
Dragon King viserys Targaryen the first
and his first wife Emma were unable to
have a male child to succeed him as King
which is customary in Westeros upon
Emma's death while in childbirth King
viserys named his eldest daughter
Ramirez as his heir to the Iron Throne
an unprecedented action which sent
shockwaves throughout the Seven Kingdoms
just a few decades before rhaeny's
Targaryen was passed over for viserys
Targaryen to sit on the Iron Throne when
the Lords of Westeros voted in his favor
in the great council at harrenhal simply
because he was a man so to solidify
Rainier's claim viserys had all the high
Lords of Westeros come to King's Landing
to pledge themselves to her as viserys's
Heir years later though viserys
remarried to Lady Allison Hightower and
had three three sons and one daughter
upon the birth of their firstborn son
aegon II many lords of the Seven
Kingdoms expected viserys to change his
mind to name aegon as his Heir instead
he held fast to Rainier his claim to the
throne which is what initially started
the internal strife between the
targaryens essentially the root of the
Civil War lies in the fact that King
viserys named his eldest child rhaenyra
as heir to the Iron Throne rather than
his eldest male child aegon so why
exactly are they called the greens and
the blacks the nicknames for each side
come from somewhat contradictory
accounts of events preceding the dance
of the dragons in the TV series House of
the Dragon Queen Allison wears a green
dress the color of her house Hightower
to the wedding Feast for rhaenira and
laner valerion when she would be
expected to wear the colors of the
family she married into black and red in
the book Fire and Blood however the
names come from a very different event a
king viserys and queen Allison's fifth
wedding anniversary Rainier wore an
extravagant red and black gown while
Alison wore a vibrant green one
thereafter it became the custom to refer
to Greens and blacks when talking about
the Queen's party and the princess's
party quick plug if you like like what
you're seeing hit that subscribe button
for more videos like this now back to
the video now that we know how each
faction got their name let's talk about
who supports each side in the greens
Corner we have Queen Allison Hightower
pushing for her son Egon II descent on
the Iron Throne along with the Hightower
family Laris strong and Sir Kristen Cole
in the blacks Corner we have princess
Rainier Targaryen and her sons along
with the king's brother Damon and the
valerion family Undeclared as of yet are
several members of King viserys's small
Council including Grand maester Melos
master of ships or Thailand Lannister
and master of coin Lord Lyman beesberry
these men and all the great and lesser
houses of the Seven Kingdoms will soon
have to make their choice some will be
swayed by promise of future advantage or
Royal marriage others by their loyalty
Duty and honor and some will try to
remain neutral to avoid the cost to
anyone involved in this war which side
has more dragons though the greens
currently have three dragons including
the largest living Dragon Veigar written
by aemond Sunfire written by aegon and
dream fire written by Helena while the
blacks have five tame dragons including
Cyrax written by rhaenyra Vermax written
by Jace karaxis written by Damon Moon
Dancer written by Bala melis written by
rhaenys and potentially more wild
dragons as they reside in Dragonstone
while the blacks have more dragons on
their side the greens are able to level
the playing field because Eamon bonded
with the dragon vegar after the death of
Lena valerion giving the greens one of
the largest and oldest dragons of all
time so for the time being the dragon
power is pretty equal between the two
factions now without spoiling anything
an important question arises which side
has the better claim to the throne
rhaenyra or aegon II under the typical
laws of succession established over the
past Century through house targaryen's
reign in Westeros aegon II would have
been Crown King over Amira in an instant
however I'd argue that rhaenyra has the
better claim simply because viserys
directly named her as his Heir and all
the great houses of the Seven Kingdoms
swore their loyalty to her the only
thing which gives aegon's claim a bit of
legitimacy is the tired tradition of men
only wanting to support male rulers
while it's understandable that Allison
should fear for her children's lives
should Rainier I send the iron throne
and that her anger towards Rainier is
only exacerbated by the incident where
Rainier's son Luke cut out the eye of
Allison's son aemond I don't think it's
quite necessary to start a whole Civil
War because of it she could instead make
peace with Rainier and support her claim
as Queen to avoid thousands of
unnecessary deaths but I'll leave it up
to you which side are you supporting the
greens or the blacks drop your thoughts
in the comment section below also check
out the video on your screen for some
more of my content don't forget to like
And subscribe and thanks for watching
Rocket rightly
thank you